hi everyone I'm Richard here today to
take a look at the new radian
rx480 yep in the wake of nvidia's Pascal
launch now it's amd's turn and it's
actually a very different strategy from
the red team here GTX 1070 and 1080 they
aim at the premium end of the graphics
Market rx480 here is for the mainstream
player priced at $199 it's all about
offering a sweet spot in terms of price
versus performance and for my money it's
very very compelling this is the AMD
reference design essentially a Triumph
of function over form if you're looking
for a premium finish you'll be wanting
one of those partner cards this one is
all about hitting that Target $199 price
point while delivering very very quiet
performance now looking at the top of
the card you'll note just one six pin
PCI Express power input the rx480 has a
TDP of just 150 WS meanwhile on the rear
you'll find three display ports
conforming to the 1.3 1.4 HDR spec along
with HDMI 2.0b but that's kind of it for
mainstream card I'd really like to have
seen a dual link DVI port and maybe
we'll see that on a partner board one
thing that is worth pointing out is that
this is an 8 GB version of the card and
this comes with faster 8 GB per second
ram now the more mainstream 4 gig
version gets 7 GB per second second
modules instead but it's that
performance that you're really
interested in right essentially what we
have here is a great competitor to two
of our favorite gpus the gtx970 and the
r9390 this is the division running at
Ultra at 1080p now you see that red line
there that's the
rx480 beating off both r9390 and gtx970
in fact it's about 9 to 10% faster
overall and it's absolutely trouncing
its predecessor the r93 80 now that was
a pretty decent card actually for its
time but the 480 is actually 48% faster
here next up Far Cry Primal now this is
an interesting one because the r9390 is
around 11% faster than the new card but
the rx480 still noses slightly ahead of
the 970 now we have to bear in mind that
some games really like memory bandwidth
Far Cry is seemingly one of them which
is why the 512-bit memory interface in
the 390 seems to work so well here and
of course there will be scenarios where
GTX 970 beats the RX 482 now Crisis 3 is
a game where the Nvidia card has a
slight win but the rise of the Tomb
Raider well running under dx12 the GTX
970 really has the advantage here but
the bottom line is this generally
speaking the overall experience is
broadly comparable to much more
expensive gpus sometimes the rx480 is a
little better sometimes it's a little
worse but the ballpark performance is
always there and of course those dx12
games where AMD dominates well of course
they still dominate check this out
Hitman under dx12 on rx480 at 1440p is
only a touch slower than the same
Benchmark running at 1080p on GTX 970
okay so what about overclocking well AMD
has updated its control panel with a new
tool that allows for much more granular
overclocking at various power States and
in this respect it's rather similar to
nvidia's GPU boost 3. zero but you can
just adjust frequency offsets as usual
the 8 GB per second ram in our reference
model here hits 8.8 easily but core
frequency well that's different I could
only get stability with a mere 4% boost
overall and this bumps up the core to
around 131 MHz from the stock 1266 now
that might not sound like a lot but that
boost clock is quite Dynamic on the 480
at stock frequencies on some games it
will stick to 1266 but in others it'll
top out around 1180 to 1200 with the
overclock in place the end result is an
extra 10% of performance generally but
efficiency drops significantly and on
the reference card here that fan really
needs to work overtime now it may well
be the case that partner boards have the
thermal solution and the power to really
push the overclock but the reference
model is pretty well balanced at stock
frequencies in terms of power
consumption well rx480 has a 150 W TDP
now under Peak load we saw that our test
system consumed around 270 wats now
that's a huge improvement over the r9390
but only a more modest saving compared
to the gtx970 and remarkably the much
more capable GTX 1070 is even more
efficient even with its Titan X level
performance all of which is fascinating
of course but what I really want to
stress is what this $200 card is
actually capable of delivering in terms
of the gameplay experience you might
have noticed that on our Channel we do a
lot of 9 70 versus 390 1080p performance
testing and the reason why is
straightforward enough these cards take
your compromis console experience and
make it a whole lot better so check this
out this is GTA 5 no msaa paired back
grass quality but everything else pretty
much maxed out 1080p 60 frames per
second twice as smooth as console with
better visuals and we're not using our
usual overclocked i7 here with fast Ram
as we do in our benchmarks this is a
Core i5 6500 paired with Bargain
Basement 2133 MHz ddr4 next up Star Wars
Battlefront dialed back settings and
900p on PS4 720p on Xbox One with rx480
I'm running this max out at ultra
settings at full 1080p now this is
another palpable upgrade over consoles
that you'll only get with a PC and
finally The Witcher 3 now this is a
pretty demanding game PS4 sees a
veritable grab bag of various graphical
settings while Xbox one has to contend
with a sub native resolution on PC with
the rx480 getting this to run locked at
1080p60 it's a piece of cake just whack
up all those settings to high turn off
nvidia's wasteful Hair Works feature and
enjoy a superb silky smooth experience
and that's the bottom line really AMD
itself where it's positioning the rx480
as the cheapest GPU available for a
premium VR experience and yeah it is
that and yeah I get that but in a world
where those headsets are still so
expensive I see this more as a card for
the players yeah that's Sony slogan for
PS4 but it's quite apt actually after
all the Polaris 10 technology found in
the rx480 takes center stage in the
upcoming PlayStation Neo console overall
then rx480 isn't the fastest GPU money
can buy but that was never the point the
cost of a superb console beating PC just
got a whole lot cheaper this is a highly
impressive value play and I'm really
looking forward to seeing the Nvidia
response okay so that's all for now
remember to like And subscribe if you
found this useful and want to support
our work but as always thanks for
watching